des arbres précieux alliés de la
biodiversité longtemps arraché pour
libérer des terres agricoles on estime
ainsi que 45000 km de haies champêtre
ont disparu en France alors depuis un
quart de siècle maintenant le Conseil
départemental d'Indre-et-Loire et la
fédération de chasse tente d'inverser le
processus en lien sociaux les nouvelles
générations Waze reportage à vers nous
sur Braine d'Hélène chapelet
le jour se lève sur la campagne de
Vernou-sur-Brenne alors que la brume
n'est pas encore dissipée une
cinquantaine d'élèves de 3e du collège
public de Vouvray investissent les
champs ils viennent reconstituer 350
mètres d'une haie bocagère sur la
parcelle d'un particulier
on va replanter 700 plans aujourd'hui
des essences différentes avec l'objectif
de recréer ce qu'on appelle des
corridors biologiques c'est-à-dire un
milieu qui est propre à accueillir une
faune sauvage soit une faune sédentaire
soit une faune migratrice des oiseaux
des passereaux du gibier
après quelques explications place à
l'action pour faire oublier les dégâts
du roman sur un film d'amidon
biodégradable les jeunes repentent des
chaînes du sureau de l'aubépine ou de
l'épine noire des arbres à baies pour
nourrir la faune locale et recréer tout
un écosystème une mise en pratique des
notions vues auparavant en cours
il y a pas que les tigres tout ça qui
disparaissent juste les oiseaux déjà en
France il y en a de moins en moins et
c'est important qui reviennent donc leur
biodiversité on a besoin
depuis le début de l'année et en vrai
j'aime bien je trouve ça je trouve ça
intéressant ça nous permet de nous
apprendre comment faire au lieu de
rester sur des cahiers et d'écrire voilà
donc ça prend l'air
bah c'est bien ouais on agit pour la
planète donc on peut être fier de nous
une opération rendue possible la grâce à
l'aide financière du Conseil
départemental d'Indre-et-Loire et à
l'aide des techniques de la fédération
départementale des chasseurs entre 2022
et 2023 20 km de s seront ainsi
replantés pour un budget de 50 000 euros